ricky gervais smashes Hollywood round
matches up the rhetoric and so does
president and Trump and democratic 2020
candidates struggle for response i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
20:20 starting off the bang the ben
shapiro show is sponsored by expressvpn
why haven't you gotten a VPN yet visit
expressvpn comm slash man how many times
I gotta tell you this expressvpn comm
slash button go check them out alrighty
so we will get to everything in the Iran
news the reason that we will delay that
for just a moment is because something
actually fun happened lesson I know when
we talk politics usually it's very
grumpy usually it's about all the
terrible things happening in the world
all the stress is happening well believe
me we'll get to all the stress we'll get
to the 2020 election we'll get to the
situation with Iran which the media are
playing up I mean they really are
they're playing up everything as though
we are at crisis level 10 right is that
we've gone all the way down to DEFCON 1
like we are we're we are all the way at
the brink of World War that is not the
case they're taking headlines and
they're exaggerating those headlines
they're taking stories and then they're
making more of the stories then then is
reality
so you're seeing stories about the
reinstitution of the draft sure yes guys
we're gonna reinstate the draft in order
to fight Iran yes I'm sure that's that's
right around the corner you're seeing
stories about the Iraqi parliament
voting to expel the America again
nope that's not that's not really the
story we'll get to all that in just a
second suffice it to say the media are
driving a lot of the wartime escalation
rhetoric that is happening right now a
president Trump is attempting to
re-establish deterrence President Trump
is doing a very very rudimentary take on
mutually assured destruction and
deterrence right here and it's driving
people on the left nuts not because they
don't like his language they don't but
because they don't like the underlying
policy and they don't like the fact that
Trump is brusque and the Trump says
something that in ways the common man
can understand it would prefer that
everything be stated in perfectly
statesmen like fashion but what they
really don't like is the message that
he's conveying not how he is conveying
the message we'll get to all of that
just think about we first have to talk
about something that was actually fun
that happened last night so the Golden
Globes happened last night now I am NOT
one to watch her the Golden Globe so I
will admit I was not watching this thing
live instead I started to see Ricky
Gervais strutting in whatever Ricky
Gervais hosts one of these shows you
know that it's going to be at the very
least amusing and maybe better than that
because Ricky Gervais does not give any
bleeps he does not care at all about the
Hollywood crowd he finds them
self-serving he finds them off-putting
he thinks they're ridiculous because
they are ok and last night at the Golden
Globes Ricky Gervais just took Hollywood
and threw them in a meat grinder ala
Fargo he just took the leading members
and they were so angry about it the
cutaways to Ricky Gervais C's jokes were
better than his joked he's the cutaways
we're all team members of the Hollywood
crowd not being able to laugh at
themselves on any level sitting there
stone-faced as Ricky Gervais just tore
them apart it was wonderful it was what
America has been waiting for Ricky
Gervais stressed spectacular we get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about why you need the Second Amendment
mean the real reason the Union you need
the Second Amendment is to ensure not
only that you are safe but also to
ensure that your rights are protected
this is the reason why the founding
fathers enshrined the Second Amendment
right after the first because they
understood that the true guarantor of
American freedom was an armed population
abiding by the law and defending its
rights well if you are a law-abiding
citizen well maybe you're looking to buy
a great rifle if you're looking to buy a
great rifle you need to work with my
friends over at Bravo Company MFG com
owning a rifle is an awesome
responsibility and so is building rifles
starting to garage buy a Marine veteran
more than two decades ago Bravo Company
manufacturing BCM for short builds a
professional-grade product built to
combat standards
Bravo company manufacturing is not a
sporting arms company they design
engineer and manufacture life-saving
equipment the people at BCM assume when
a rifle leaves their shop it will in
fact be used in a life-or-death
situation by a responsible citizen law
enforcement officer or soldier overseas
which is a good assumption in fact is
I'm not buying a gun so that I can go
hunting I'm not a hunter I'm buying a
gun because I don't make sure that I'm
safe my rights are safe to learn more
about Bravo Company manufacturing head
on over to Bravo Company MFG comm where
you can discover more about their
products special offers and upcoming
news that's Bravo Company MFG comm if
you need more convincing find out even
more about BCM and the awesome people
who make their products at youtube.com
slash Bravo Company USA and that's
youtube.com slash Bravo Company USA well
if you are one of the millions hundreds
of millions of Americans who are
irritated by Hollywood celebrities
mouthing off on politics or irritated by
the fact that these Hollywood
celebrities declare themselves are moral
betters that these Hollywood celebrities
act like socialists while earning like
capitalists that they live high on the
hog
where they drink their swill and down
their steaks and eat their foie gras and
they turn around and tell all of us that
our consumptive habits are simply too
much well they live in these mansions in
in Malibu
well proclaiming that people who are in
the suburbs of Los Angeles should simply
allow homeless people to sleep on their
doorsteps with open needles these same
people who lecture us day in and day out
are some of the most derelict moral
characters on planet earth and they're
they're the people who will look the
other way so long as it profits them
there are people who will fully ignore
all of the horror that goes around them
the human carnage that goes around them
every day and how that I'm speaking
particularly about the treatment of
women or Hollywood basically allowed
that to go on for decades on end there's
literally a statue of a casting couch in
the middle of Beverly Hills California
because the casting couch was so
prevalent in Hollywood these same people
who are willing to work for any company
so long as they get their buck who are
willing to take a private jet anywhere
these same people will lecture you on
global warming and how you really need
to set your thermostat differently in
the wintertime well Ricky Gervais was
having none of it last night and the
nice thing about Ricky Gervais is that
he's from outside the country so because
Ricky Gervais is British that means that
he is allowed a certain amount of scorn
for the Hollywood celebs being a form
that gives you a certain amount of
credibility when you speak about
Americans and their ridiculous habits
and so Ricky Gervais coming to the
United States obviously very funny dude
and he just went at Hollywood last night
hammer and tongs and they couldn't help
themselves because Ricky Gervais went
after them for being self aggrandizing
and self serving an awful and then they
would promptly get up and give speeches
proving that they were at self
aggrandizing and self serving an awful
and they shouldn't be trusted on any
moral level they shouldn't be trusted on
any political level okay so that's a
pretty good pitch for Ricky's race by
the way the media many of them went nuts
on him last night
slate had an entire piece about how mean
he was he's so mean I'm amazed that's
that so many on the left are now very
very much upset with comedians being
mean literally they will they will
praise any comedian who figuratively
takes a dump on president Trump's head
but if Ricky Gervais says one unkind
word about the Hollywood glitterati then
he's a very bad man there's
printed an entire piece about Ricky
Gervais sees bad old tweets cuz they're
trying to get him cancelled the same way
that they got Kevin Hart cancelled from
the Oscars a Ricky Gervais again because
he's not subjected to their whims
he just went directly at all of these
people last night and he did so in a
variety of ways there's pretty
spectacular so here are a couple of
examples first he went after Hollywood
for the Jeffrey Epstein associations
made Jeffrey Epstein joke Jeffrey
Epstein didn't kill himself joke now as
you know every Jeffrey Epstein didn't
kill himself joke is a funny joke there
is no such thing as an unfunny Jeffrey
Epstein didn't kill himself joke me so
Ricky Gervais straps one when the people
in the room are stone-faced how dare he
it's so offensive how could he make a
Jeffrey Epstein didn't kill himself -
first of all that's like the least
offensive joke in the world Jeffrey
Epstein didn't kill himself is a very
very not offensive joke but he makes
this joke and everybody minam's like and
then he drops the hammer on them season
two is on the way so in the end he
obviously didn't kill himself just like
Jeffrey Epstein shut up I know he's your
friend but I don't care
you got to make your own way air in your
own plane didn't ya and some of them are
laughing but it's a very awkward laugh
like the only person in the audience
who's truly laughing all the jokes the
atom driver who seems to be a delightful
human being and I kind of like Adam
driver actually is like yeah this is
kind of funny everybody else in the
audience is like I'm laughing in spite
of myself there's the girl from the
woman from the Gilmore Girls
they giving the the very very upset face
how could he tell a Jeffrey Epstein and
point out that we hang out with the
world's worst human beings how how could
he just okay the best poke a then he
then he dropped the real bomb okay at
the very end of this eight-minute
monologue where he just ripped Hollywood
up and down he then turned to the moral
character of the people in Hollywood and
he said you guys gotta stop lecturing us
because let's be real about this you
guys have no moral grounds upon which to
stand Tim Cook was in the audience
because of Apple TV and Ricky Gervais
just took out a machete and went after
everyone in the audience my goodness
a superb drama about the importance of
dignity and doing the right thing made
by a company that runs sweatshops in
China so will you say you woke but the
companies you work for I mean
unbelievable Apple Amazon Disney if Isis
started a streaming service you'd call
your agent wouldn't you so if you do win
an award tonight don't use it sir a
platform to make a political speech
right you're in no position to lecture
the public about anything you know
nothing about the real world most of you
spent less time in school than Greta
Thumb Berg so if you win right come up
exceptionally an award take your agent
and your God okay in the Paris he tells
them to ever okay yes yes okay we've all
of America becomes meg Ryan in the diner
scene in When Harry Met Sally excellent
job Ricky correct correct because
listening to all of these promise asses
lecture all of us about morality while
they're on their ninth wife while flying
in private jets all around the world
lecturing us about our consumption
habits while they work for companies
that they decry as brutal and awful the
same people who who will champion aoc
trying to get Amazon kicked out of New
York will work for Amazon when it comes
to Amazon
I'm right the all of these people are
hypocrites beyond belief and not only
are they hypocrisy here's the thing I'm
being a hypocrite they're not just
hypocrites it's that they are hypocrites
who hold themselves to a different
standard than everybody else so the left
likes to talk a lot without hypocrisy
where you have a standard but you don't
live up to that standard
that's not hypocrisy that's called just
being a human being having a standard
and then not holding yourself to the
standard and believing it is righteous
not to hold yourself to a standard that
is the kind of hypocrisy that Hollywood
constantly engages in and Ricky Gervais
just says it out loud you know the
funniest part about the Golden Globes is
that then all of these actors and
actresses got up and did the exact thing
that Ricky Gervais stoled them not to do
like the exactly they got up in they
lectured us all on politics when they
have no clue what's going on the real
world when they have no relationship
with the vast majority of Americans when
their morals are 180 degrees polar
opposite from what most Americans
believe and feel is right so Ricky
Gervais sets the stage and then all of
these people just proceeded to fall
right in the trap I'm going to show you
that in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that you must be on top
of your own business if you wish your
business remain profitable and
successful at daly where we have an
entire finance and accounting department
to track all the numbers but you might
not have that right you might have a
small company you can't afford an entire
department it makes sense and it
requires you to have an integrated
system for all of your numbers if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business but the problem that
growing businesses have that keeps them
from knowing their numbers that there
are a lot of different systems you've
been using on an ad hoc basis as you
build your business for years well now
it's time to get integrated with
NetSuite with NetSuite by Oracle it's
the business management software that
handles every aspect of your business
and an easy to use cloud platform giving
you the visibility and control you need
to grow with NetSuite you save time and
money and unneeded headaches by managing
sales finance and accounting orders and
HR instantly directly from your desktop
or phone this is why NetSuite is the
world's number one cloud business system
managing a business without
understanding our numbers huge mistake
you lose a lot of money and a lot of
time through the cracks instead you need
NetSuite comm slash Schapiro right now
NetSuite is offering you valuable
insights with a free guide seven key
strategies to grow your profits at
NetSuite comm Shapiro that's any TSU i
te comm slash Shapiro NetSuite comm
slash up here to download that free
guide seven key strategies to grow your
profits again NetSuite com
/ Shapiro ok so then all of these
Hollywood idiots get up and proceeded to
do exactly what Ricky Gervais told them
not to do lecture Americans based on
their lack of knowledge and this this
self-assured sense that they are
speaking on behalf of most Americans and
Michelle Williams gets up her hair dyed
Marilyn Monroe platinum and wearing
apparently a garbage bag on her shoulder
I don't know I don't know what that's
maybe that has some meaning if it
doesn't then this is just a hideous
dress in any case Michelle Williams gets
up and she starts lecturing the public
on abortion ok now what's hilarious
about this is you just heard Ricky
Gervais said most of you have less
education and then Greta Thun Berg this
is literally true of Michelle Williams
Michelle Williams dropped out of school
at 15 she dropped out of school at 15 at
the behest of her parents and then she
declared herself in it she declared
herself free from her parents right she
actually filed legal forms so that she
could be removed from the care of her
parents with their permission so that
she could work as an underage actress
and avoid child labor laws and so this
is the same left that will declare that
it's the right that wants children to
work well then cheer people who declare
themselves independent at age 15 s that
they can go work in Hollywood making
whatever schmutz they decide to make so
Michelle Williams gets up this person
who again has no relationship with
people in in the real world and she
explains on behalf of women everywhere
that what is deeply necessary is
abortion that she would not be where she
is at right now without abortion again
let me just say this if you're talking
about the strength of women and your
suggestion is that female strength is so
great
that you just need to kill a few babies
in order to get ahead let me suggest
that it's not a case for female
independence and strength here's
Michelle Williams wearing a dress
directly from like the Hari Krishna in
the 1970s in a garbage bag on her left
shoulder explaining about abortion I've
tried my very best to live a life of my
own making and not just a series of
events that happened to me but one that
I could stand back and look at and
recognize my handwriting all over
sometimes messy and scrawling sometimes
careful and precise but one that I had
carved with my own hand and I wouldn't
have been able to do this without
employing
a woman's right to choose thank God or
whomever you pray to that we live in a
country founded on the principle that I
am free to live by my faith and you are
free to live by yours
so women 18 to 118 when it is time to
vote please do so in your own
self-interest right on the verge of
tears always on the first years because
since killing babies and then I love the
cutaways to all the women looking so so
serious the cutaways again are the best
part of this show right the cutaways
Glenn Close looking on yes yes without
abortion I wouldn't have been able to
boil a rabbit without abortion
I wouldn't been on damages and then some
young woman I've never seen before
and then you've got the cutaways of all
the women looking very serious so
serious and then you've got the cutaway
of Michelle Pfeiffer just gazing into
counter this because this is so
meaningful it's so meaningful when
Michelle Williams an extraordinarily
rich and famous and beautiful woman says
that she would not be where she is at
without having employed the right to
choose which I assume means that she had
an abortion so now she's making the case
that she would not be where she has had
namely rich and famous without a dead
body along her way that's not a great
case for your own independence and moral
superiority and if you're thanking God
for your abortion your ability to get an
abortion let me suggest a tank god
you're talking to right there that ain't
God you're talking about is something
else it's your own ego that you are
worshipping and again Michelle Williams
fulfilling everything that Ricky Gervais
said not to do and then it wasn't just
Michelle Williams his bizarro world
Patricia Arquette who is a who's a
weirdo who showed up wearing a pair of
sunglasses apparently purchased at the
Disney accessory store and she won for a
show called the act
I guess she won Best Supporting Actress
and so she decided that she was gonna
lecture Americans also she's gonna
lecture Americans about Trump because
that's what that's what everybody loves
what people love most of all if you want
to convince Americans not to vote for
Trump what you need is more empty-headed
idiotic actors and actresses from
Hollywood who have no relationship with
anyone who lives between Los Angeles and
New York wearing sunglasses in the
middle of the night on a well-lit stage
explaining that President
is a very very bad man who's very bad in
orange and bad we're not gonna look back
on this night in the history books we
will see a country on the brink of war
the United States of America a president
tweeting out a threat of 52 bombs
including cultural sites young people
risking their lives travelling across
the world people not knowing if bombs
are gonna drop on their kids heads and
the continent of Australia on fire what
the f is she talking about and also did
she steal those glasses from Bono's
closet and also why is everyone in the
audience as serious about this like no
one in the audience is just rolling
their eyes
no one all these same people like I love
this all the same people that Trump is a
none serious person he's an unserious
president very unserious we need a
serious man in office you know who
should lead the way Patricia Arquette
that's what we need we need more
celebrities more celebrities we're gonna
tell us what to do you built this guys
hey you you want to know how Trump
became president because of you because
of you because you worshipped celebrity
you made Barack Obama who is a
politician into a celebrity you give him
a Netflix deal you turned all of your
favorite politicians into celebrities
and all of your favorite celebrities
into politicians and then you are
shocked when Americans respond by
electing a celebrity to the presidency
who just happens not to agree with you
don't give me the oh we need we need
people who are well-spoken you're
sitting there cheering Patricia Arquette
couldn't string a sentence together if
it was scripted for her she barely can
when it is scripted for her you're
sitting there cheering Michelle Williams
who again dropped out of school at age
15 to pursue her acting career as some
sort of political leader you guys are
looking for your moral guidance to the
ladies of Charmed Rose McGowan and
Alyssa Milano these are the people you
prop up and they're like oh well you
know from yes because of you because of
you this is because of you okay so you
guys brought this on yourselves you
brought this on yourselves and it is
smarmy and it is gross and it is
disgusting I've said this many times
since from selection Patricia Arquette
is why you got Trump Michelle Williams
is why you got Trump because the rest of
the country feels like Ricky Gervais
here shut up you don't know what you're
talk
about when I say shut up I don't mean
you don't have the right say what you
want to say you have the right say what
you want to say but you're idiots and
you don't know what you're talking about
and it doesn't give you added
credibility in what you're talking about
because you're good at acting words that
other people write it does not give you
added credibility to speak on top on
topics of public importance simply
because you throw a football like Colin
Kaepernick into a pick six it doesn't
matter okay no one can and so Trump is
just a giant middle finger right he's
always been a pulsating giant middle
finger and don't worry we'll get to more
of this pulsating giant middle finger
when it comes to Iran policy because it
turns out that celebrities also have
been sounding off not just at the Golden
Globes but more broadly about Trump's
and Ron policy because when I think of
well well it's well sort of considered a
Ron policy the first place I look
theoretically is to people like cardi B
and Colin Kapernick those are the places
that I look America is Ricky Gervais
okay Ricky Gervais says take on this was
exactly right we're gonna get to the
most brutal Ricky Gervais hit of all at
the Golden Globes last night
first let's talk about how you can make
your employees better so let's say that
you had an employee let's say that his
name was I don't know Ryan and let's say
that one day this Ryan just decided you
know what it's a really early show we
get up early in the morning to do the
show and guess what I was out late last
night and my alarm didn't work and I'm
just gonna show up like an hour late to
work and you know everybody else will
pick up the slack and maybe feels bad
but you know what you know what isn't
here like a zipper career zip recruiter
see this is the nice thing about our
zipper career adds it provide me not
only with an ability to get you to
recruit better people for your business
but for me to threaten my employees with
the possibility of unemployment zip
recruiter com it sends your job to over
100 of the web's leading job boards but
they don't stop there with their
powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and then invite them to apply to your
job as applications come in zip
recruiter analyzes each one spotlights
the top candidates so you never miss a
great match zip recruiter is so
effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate through the site
within the very first day right now my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire that zip
recruiter comm slash Dai ly Wira zip
recruiter comm slash daily wired make
sure
that when you put in the requirements
for jobs make sure that you put in being
prompt Ryan zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire his her ricky
gervais says final joke here was the
best joke spot his way he was so
irritated with the whole process it was
quite wonderful so he's talking here
about about the the movies that have
been nominated in the in the horror
category I believe and he's talking
about bird box and he just levels
Hollywood it's fantastic starred in
Netflix his bird box a movie where
people survive by acting like they don't
see a thing sorta like working for
Harvey Weinstein what are you going
about he's right you did it you you
pieces a crap you're the ones who spent
30 years taking Harvey Weinstein's
checks while allowing him to peek down
your blouse and or allowing him to feet
down other people's blouses and then
some of you come for like again I have
nothing but sympathy for the women who
haven't actually come for but they're a
bunch of women who didn't come forward
and or protected Harvey Weinstein
knowing that he did this stuff or he did
it to them and then they came out and
protected him for years because he was
signing checks to them so no don't get
Hollywood does not get to stand on its
high horse about me to Hollywood does
not get to stand on his high horse about
global warming honestly the only person
who was even decent in these political
speeches last night was walking Phoenix
he got played off the stage when he
suggested that people in Hollywood stop
taking private jets everywhere
Joaquin Phoenix may be a nut but at
least he's enough who's trying to hold
himself to a standard
yeah Ricky Gervais has hit on Hollywood
it does underscore what our politics
truly is about
these days because it really is not
about the complexity of politics it
really is about this cultural divide you
know culture the cultural wars have
become extremely hard fought a lot more
hard fought in the last 20 years 25
years than they were for many decades
before that why what culture is usually
the vast vest the last vestige of unity
so when you have a common philosophy
culture history then culture tends to be
the easiest place to unify because
you're gonna argue about TV you can
argue about sports really gonna argue
about like the products that you're
wearing that's the stuff that's easy the
stuff that's hard is philosophy and
history
and all the stuff that that undergirds a
successful civilization but when all of
those other things fall away and the
last thing that we can unify about is
culture and then culture starts to be
polarized we end up in these culture
wars we're fighting and you can see with
each successive Oscars each successive
Golden Globes
you can see that Hollywood is
exacerbating those culture wars and
Ricky Gervais just put a pin in it last
night I mean he really just exposed it
ripped it wide open he made another joke
that I don't think we actually had a
chance to pull where he was talking
about the woke nature of Hollywood and
he was saying that he was going to do an
in memoriam segment last night but he
saw that there are too many dead white
people he said well I'm not gonna do
that that's not diverse enough that's
not that I'm not gonna be the one who
does that and people in the audience
didn't know whether to laugh or not
because what he is laughing at is their
ridiculous insistence that every single
part has to be given to a person who is
of the actual physical description in
the in the in the script so if it's a
disabled person it can't be a person who
is non-disabled playing a disabled
person which is called acting he's
laughing at the fact that Hollywood has
declared that the only way that they can
find some sort of moral recompense for
what they do is by hiring a certain
percentage of black or gay or female
actors and that you have to have a
certain percentage of black or female or
gay lines in a particular script in
order to make that script morally
praiseworthy it Ricky Gervais is right
about all this Hollywood has been at the
forefront of the culture wars and then
they declare themselves on the defensive
oh how dare these right wingers like
krump they're always involved in the
culture wars you launched it Trump was
just responding so as the rest of
America and Gervase honestly like people
on the right were cheering lesson
teacher vase is not a Republican the
guys see no evidence that your vase is
conservative a Republican he just has
eyes that's all he has eyes and he has a
brain and so he can see how ridiculous
these people in Hollywood are and they
are ridiculous pretending to be our
moral butters just absurdity okay
meanwhile on to the more serious news of
the day so the situation over Iran is
intensifying but in reality the the
possibility of violence with Iran has
actually decreased not increased over
the past 24 hours so if you watch the
media what you're saying is that the
possibility of violence overt violence
war with Iran is increasing radically
and that the United States is going to
go to overt war with
first of all President Trump does not
want this anyone who tells you
difference is lying to you
lying overtly to your face hey Trump
does not want this this cuts against
everything Trump's believe Trump
believes about the middle east he's been
consistent on one thing and one thing
only over the last 10 years and that is
he does not like involvement in the
Middle East the only reason that he is
doing all of this is because Iran burned
our Embassy lest we forget
if the Iranians burned our embassy last
week and that was after engaging in a
year of full-on aggression attacking
ships in the Straits of Hormuz the going
after Saudi oil facilities shooting down
American drones firing on American bases
trying to kill American allies arming
terrorist groups ranging from Lebanon to
Yemen so this this notion that Trump is
like itching for war it's just a bunch
of horse crap it's just a bunch of horse
crap and by the way the idea that we're
going to sort of slide into a war with
Iran and that Trump is doing all of this
because he wants to Telegraph a war for
the 2020 election and this is just like
a rock it's like people have no memories
in this country here the Iraq war was
telegraphed for a full year
george w bush went to the UN for
resolutions six seven eight months
before the war in iraq began was the
longest telegraph punch in human history
this is not a telegraph punch Trump is
just trying to re-establish a deterrence
that didn't exist under Barack Obama
because Barack Obama was too busy
bribing the terrorists so you may think
that this is brinksmanship by Trump it's
also called reestablishing deterrence it
turns out that appeasement lowers your
level of commitment to the possibility
of conflict but it heightens the other
side's willingness to seek conflict
which is what we've seen over the past
several years over the past decade or so
but according to the media chances with
war have never been greater now as
you'll see this is not actually true the
Iranians strategy has shifted from we
are going to pursue acts of violence to
we are going to try and pursue political
ends in places like Iraq to minimize the
American footprint and that's their
actual strategy right now it is not to
engage in vast amounts of violence
against American troops overseas they
know that that will end with Ayatollah
heads not being connected to ayatollah
bodies instead what they are seeking to
do is pursue political ends in Iraq that
are designed to push the American troops
out of Iraq and therefore give Iran yet
another foothold in the Middle East
that's a smart thing to do
is the United States ain't gonna listen
to it because the fact is that the Iraqi
government unfortunately is dominated in
many ways by Iranian front groups this
is one of the reasons why they've had
thousands of people protesting in the
streets against the current sitting
Prime Minister of Iraq who stuck between
a rock and a hard place
literally Iraq and a hard place being
Iran okay but if you watch the media
we're on the verge of a draft we're not
on the verge of a draft if you watch the
media oh my god Iran's gonna pull out of
the nuclear deal and they're gonna
they've been doing this for months oh my
god Iraq is passing a resolution that
says that of air America has to get
that's a non-binding resolution right
now what Trump is doing is not riskier
than what was happening when the United
States was simply bending over backwards
for the ayatollahs and allowing them to
be as violent as they wanted to be
across the entire Middle East but here
is the latest breaking news oh the
crowds were out in Tehran chanting death
to America my favorite thing about the
news is that so often it is not new so
the UK Daily Mail says angry crowds
chant death to America and hold signs
vowing revenge a funeral of top Iranian
general Qasem Soleimani after he was
killed in u.s. airstrikes as thousands
hold us anti us rally in Tehran wait
wait you mean they're holding rallies in
Tehran where they don't like the United
States and and chants out to America
this is brand-new I've never heard
anything like this ever before except
for every year every single year I've
been alive and years before that since
death to America is a thing it's been a
thing for quite a while and massive
rallies where they burn American flags
and talk about America is the Great
Satan yeah that stuff that's nothing new
so if you're just tuning in now you're
coming in like season 21 of this thing
if you just discovered the Simpsons now
you're like 20 years too late if you
just discovered that the Iranians don't
like America meaning the Iranian
government doesn't like America and that
they can get thousands of people out in
the streets in a country of tens of
millions of people they get a few
thousand people out in the streets to
yell about America at gunpoint
well shocker it turns out him in doing
this for quite a while meanwhile Iran
has vowed to hit 35 US targets and
unfurled the red flag of war as America
said it expected retaliation within
weeks that retaliation is likely to come
in the form of probably terror attacks
on proxy groups right on in Yemen and
the Saudis maybe on the Israelis Iran
vows hit 35 us targets my favorite is
that they unfurled this
flag of war over a giant mosque right
widget which which obviously says
important cultural site and peaceful
plays if you are unfurling flags of war
over your holy sites or storing weapons
in there or letting terrorists hide in
there which has been historically a
thing if you look at for example
Israel's wars with with Hezbollah or
with Hamas very often people hide in
mosques specifically because they know
that the West is never going to attack
those places the war in Iraq this was a
very very common tactic Afghanistan was
a common tactic as well when you're in
for red flags over your mosque declaring
war okay it wasn't us that just declared
that site a war site you did can you
know what we don't do in the United
States in the middle of a war unfertile
war flags to let people know that a war
is coming over our big churches in the
in any case Iran pinpointed thirty five
key US targets for revenge after it
stopped General was assassinated
according to the Sun hours later rockets
were fired near the US Embassy in
Baghdad and had an air base housing
American troops now again we're gonna
pretend that this is something new this
is not anything new it's not anything
new at all actually it turns out that
rocket attacks against American bases in
Iraq have been going on for months on
end the two attacks came just hours
after Morris chance of death to America
at the funeral for Qasem Soleimani
a staffer a senior congressional staffer
said that a retaliation attack from Iran
could be seen within weeks either at
home or abroad the staffer said there's
no indication there's going to be a
de-escalation in the near future the
only question is how bad their
retaliation is going to be tonight
Lebanon's Hezbollah told the Iraqi
soldiers to leave US bases the Islamic
political and militant group also warned
Iraqi soldiers to stay at least a
thousand meters away from American
military bases from Sunday onwards what
they're trying to do is carve off the
Iraqis from the Americans that is not
likely to be a successful effort because
the Sunnis in Iraq know that the minute
the United States leaves guess who's
going to be on the wrong end of the
Iranian gun and ain't going to be the
United States anymore missiles also
rained down on Baghdad Zed's RIA
neighborhood wounding five people the
chillin flag display was seen as a clear
warning that the Islamic Republic is
ready to fulfill its worrying flag
fulfill its worrying pledge chillingly
written across the war flag were the
words those who want to avenge the blood
of Hussein it was hoisted above the
important jamjam Karan mosque which is
on the outskirts of the hole
city of Qom about a hundred miles south
of to head on him meanwhile the US fast
response force has flown to the Middle
East according to the Associated Press
being a US soldier in a fast response
force sometimes means being sent halfway
across the world within a day leaving no
time to say goodbye to those staying
behind that's what happened when able to
April Schumer when her husband a member
of the 82nd Airborne Division at Fort
Bragg got the call her husband was among
hundreds of US soldiers deployed
Saturday from Fort Bragg North Carolina
to Kuwait to serve as reinforcements in
the Middle East amid rising tensions
following the u.s. killing of a top
Iranian official so the United States is
preparing enough forces that can respond
in case of the Iranians upping the
aggression and by the way it was the
Iranians that up the aggression yeah
this thing did not start with the United
States any time Iran wants to enter the
family of nations all they have to do is
stop acting like a terror state but
they're not going to do that but it's
funny to watch members of the left and
members of the media suggests that it's
America that is deeply terroristic that
it's America that escalated this thing
now America is just reestablishing lines
that were blown away by the Obama
administration and ignored by the Obama
administration
it's called deterrence it is called
deterrence President Trump for his part
is is fighting back against thoughts
we'll get to Trump's response we'll also
get to the suppose it two big stories
over the weekend the media really
playing up Iran quote-unquote pulling
out of the nuclear agreement and the and
the claim that the Iraqi parliament has
voted in favor of getting rid of US
troops we'll get to that in just one
second first you know that this year is
gonna be a crazy news field year we're
like three days into the news cycle and
it's already nuts but with the upcoming
election impeachment attempts the Iran
situation Democratic cage matches
there's a bot coming up we know you need
to know everything that's going on the
best way to stay informed on all things
2020 is to become a daily wire member
and get comprehensive news and opinion
from us on demand so we are giving you
20% off all memberships today it's the
last day today like now do it now it's
the last day to get 20% off of all
memberships when you use promo code dwu
2020 members get our articles had free
access to all of our live broadcast and
show library the full three hours of the
ben shapiro show select bonus content to
access the mailbag and more plus our new
all access to your get you into live
online Q&A discussions with me Andrew
Klavan matt walsh michael moles plus our
site's writers and special guests with
all of the
crazy election updates coming let us
answer your questions and guide you
along this path as we move toward
November again that is promo code DW
twenty twenty four twenty percent off
today and today only joined today stay
informed on all things twenty twenty
related again that's promo code DW
twenty twenty four twenty percent off
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
you
okay so what are the latest escalations
well there are there are a few
escalations one again the the Iranians
are gonna use their proxy groups so
there was in fact a in an attack on a US
military base in Kenya one u.s. service
member to defense contractors were
killed the likelihood that that was
connected in some way to Iran's global
terror network probably pretty high as I
say proxy attacks by terror groups on
Americans are possible and likely but
the main thing is going to be trying to
attack American allies not America
directly because the Iranians are on
notice that if they move too strongly
against the United States there will be
other people who end up the same way
that Soleimani did the last thing going
through their brain being a missile so
what are their major moves well
according to the New York Times Iran has
now ended its nuclear limits as killing
of Iranian general appends Middle East
the consequences of America's targeted
killing of a senior Iranian commander
are mounting so now they're very upset
so they're pulling out of the nuclear
deal own they're not pulling out of the
nuclear deal by the way worthwhile
noting they're ending abiding by the
limits on the nuclear deal in fact javad
zarif who is again their terror friendly
foreign minister he says there will be
no longer be any restriction on number
of centrifuges this step is within jcpoa
and all five steps are reversible upon
effective implementation of reciprocal
obligations so in other words they're
not pulling out on the Iran deal Iran
itself had to refute that claim so that
isn't that is not correct
also the other story which is that the
Iraqi parliament had voted to get rid of
American troops that should create sort
of an international crisis because then
would it be legitimate for America to
have its troops in Iraq it would create
a serious crisis for the Iraqi
government which is already operating in
the absence of any sort of consensus
from the Iraqi people the current prime
minister of Iraq is already acting he's
the acting prime minister because he
resigned a few weeks ago because so many
of his own people were angry with him
because they see him as an Iranian tool
but the bottom line is that the Iraqi
parliament made a non-binding decision
request okay they requested cancellation
of assistance to the us-led anti-isis
coalition they requested to expel
foreign troops a state monopoly of arms
they filed to complain about the United
States than want an investigation of US
bombings but it's non-binding okay so in
other words that was symbolic it's being
treated as non symbolic by the media as
though
the rock is on the verge of throwing
America out of Iraq which of course is
not true Trump himself responded to this
he said well if they do that then we'll
put sanctions on Iraq too because at
that point it's pretty obvious that Iraq
is a tool of Iran the notion that the
Iranians were abiding by the nuclear
deal and therefore the nuclear deal was
the be-all end-all is just ridiculous on
its face the fact is that the nuclear
Iran nuclear deal was designed so
narrowly that it only accomplished one
thing and then declared that all
problems had been solved which is sort
of like you know some a patient comes in
to a doctor and says I have cancer and I
also have a cold and the doctor is like
well you know what here is some here is
some cold medication should work on the
runny nose you're healed giggle away to
saying what happened to cancer wasn't
the cancer like a big problem no no I
saw listen I solved the problem that I
was here to solve I was here to solve
the cold I was not here to solve the
cancer okay that's what the Iran nuclear
deal was it was okay we're gonna give
you like a little we'll give a little
band-aid so that the Iran nuclear
program is put on hold for a little
while after ten years they can develop
it fully in coordination with law and
also in the meantime we're just gonna
let the cancerous Iranian support of
terrorism occur with additional funding
in fact we are going to feed the cancer
okay that was the Iran nuclear deal so
the fact that Iran has now said that
they're violating the provisions of the
centrifuge agreements they could do that
at any time hey that was always the
threat and the notion that the the Trump
administration is somehow responsible
for the Iranians acting like terrorists
is simply ridiculous on its face Pompeyo
by the way Mike Pompeo the Secretary of
State who is largely seen by outside
sort of analysts as them as one of the
driving forces behind the Soleimani
strike he was asked about the Iraqi
Prime Minister calling for US troops to
leave the country and he was like no I
know okay this guy is he's already not
acting under a legitimate color of law
because his own he resigned right he's
the acting prime minister because his
own people see him as a tool of the
Iranians here is my Pompeo what you see
on TV expelling 5,000 US troops the
acting Prime Minister of Iraq who
resigned because of massive Iranian
interference in his own government's
ability to execute sovereignty and
independence for rockets why he left but
United States now voted you know it is
the United States that is prepared to
help the Iraqi people get what it is
they deserve and continue our mission
there to take down terrorism from Isis
and others in the region that is in
defense of the Iraqi people and it's
good for America too
okay what a Pompeo is saying there is
absolutely correct if you have a proxy
prime minister of iraq who is basically
just an irani and tool and he's telling
you to leave why would you possibly
listen to that especially when it's
endangering American assets and when the
Iranians are engaging in greater and
greater terrorism and our create this
whole thing is designed to deter Iran
from regional aggression so you're gonna
pull out because the Iraqis who are now
run by Iran are telling you to like how
does that make any sense hey so
president Trump responds and president
from always responds in the most blunt
possible way and people are going crazy
over this because Trump is tweeting
things out oh no he's tweeting things
out okay let's be clear about this if
President Trump were the most
well-spoken president in American
history if you were Abraham Lincoln and
George Washington combined if he was
their love child and if he had said in
the most articulate possible way that
Iran cannot be allowed to expand its
terroristic threat and should they
threaten American allies or assets then
we will act to the fullest extent not
only to prevent that but to deter that
in the future there would not be one
fewer shriek on the left because you
know he used to say that Barack Obama
the reason that the left didn't reek
about it is they knew Obama was lying
Obama always used to say all measures
all measures are on the table are
they're all on the table
ranging from appeasement to kissing ass
to appeasement
all of those around the table also
military force but mostly just
appeasement in kissing ass and also
ablaze but and the month was like oh my
god what inarticulate Oh what an
articulate unbelievable man this Obama
is because they knew that the military
force was never on the table
they knew that deterrence had not been
established with Iran in the same way it
was not established with Syria the same
left that is that is so just upset about
the the possibility of any violence
being done to deter Iranian violence
they were perfectly sanguine with Barack
Obama blowing up Libya allowing the Arab
Spring to completely topple regimes that
were friendly to the United States in
many cases and make way for Muslim
Brotherhood regimes in places like Egypt
they're perfectly happy with Syria
turning into a complete and utter
hellhole a hellscape with half a million
dead and millions of refugees because
Barack Obama that he was a good
president he's Barack Obama and we know
Barack Obama articulate also Barack
Obama Wow
I mean like just brilliant wreck the
Middle East but brilliant Donald Trump
however very bad Donald Trump idiot
because Donald Trump just says in very
blunt language what everybody knows we
are talking about when he say deterrence
okay the basic theory of deterrence is
this if you punch me I will end you
that's the basic theory of deterrence
hey in one sentence you punch me I end
you and so the idea is oh knowing that
I'm gonna end you you don't punch me now
see that's how deterrence works you were
just deterred from action we use it with
our children all the time if you do X I
will do Y and Y will not be
proportionate Y will be wildly
disproportionate if you yell at me I
will put you in your room and I will
take away your toys and in personal in
personal fights okay the idea is to
establish enough of a level of
deterrence that the other side does not
cross you what you don't want is
proportionality it's always amazing to
me when you watch an international law
people like well this was why it was so
disproportionate you know what
proportionality leads to actual
escalation you know how we know this
this is exactly what happened in Vietnam
in Vietnam there was an actual strategy
undertaken by the Secretary of Defense
Robert McNamara and Robert McNamara
suggested that we pursue a policy of
what he called graduated escalation in
which we slowly increased the pressure
on the Vietcong and sooner or later they
get the message as opposed to the
generalized prior to that policy of
American overwhelming force you hit us
we end you hey that is a better way to
deter action from knows this it also
happens to drive with his personal brand
of testosterone-driven politics so
president Trump tweets this out and
people lose their minds so President
Trump says Iran is talking very boldly
about targeting certain US assets as
revenge for our right ridding the world
of their terrorist leader who had just
killed an American and badly wounded
many others not to mention all of the
people he had killed over his lifetime
including recently hundreds of Iranian
protesters he was already attacking our
embassy and preparing for additional
hits in other locations Iran has been
nothing but problems for many years let
this serve as a warning that if Iran
strikes any Americans or American assets
we have targeted 52 Iranian sites
representing the 52 American hostages
taken by Iran many years ago some at a
very high level and important to Iran in
the Iranian culture and those targets in
Iran
self will be hit very fast and very hard
the USA wants no more threats everybody
goes nuts they go nuts for two reasons
one he mentioned that some of these
sites may have cultural value okay and
AOC is like that's a war crime targeting
cultural sites okay that's not how I
read the tweet what I read the tweet as
is it's a military site with cultural
importance which by the way when you're
talking about terror States it's what
they literally raised a war flag over a
culturally important mosque if they're
hiding weapons and terrorists in there
he's just saying I'm not gonna hold back
just because they're hiding weapons and
terrorists in a mosque
that's what Trump is saying when ASU
tweets out this is a war crime you know
the same lady who presumably would like
no sanctions on actual Iranian
terrorists threatening to target and
kill innocent families women and
children which is what you're doing by
targeting cultural sites note that no no
does not make you a tough guy it does
not make you strategic it makes you a
monster did he say about targeting
innocence anywhere in there or families
and women and children anywhere in that
in those Suites and Trump tweeted they
attacked us we'll hit back if they
attack again
which I would strongly advise them not
to do it'll hit them harder than they
have ever been hit before
right this is a very basic brusque way
of establishing deterrents and then
Trump goes to sort of his sort of you
know typical stick about people owing us
money the United States just spend two
trillion dollars on military equipment
we are the biggest and by far the best
in the world if we run attacks an
American base or any American will be
sending some of that brand new beautiful
equipment their way and without
hesitation right Trump is just gonna say
this over and over now is that
believable or not for the most part it
had not been until he killed some amount
he now it's suddenly believable and then
he was getting all sorts of flak from
the media he didn't notify Congress
beforehand he didn't notify Congress
before he did all of this because maybe
he had short notice he doesn't it is not
required under law that the
commander-in-chief of the United States
military notify Congress when he already
has authority to strike him by the way
he did have authority for this strike
and so Trump facetiously says these
media posts will serve as notifications
the United States Congress that should
Iran strike any US person or target the
United States will quickly and fully
strike back and perhaps in a
disproportionate manner such legal
notice is not required but is given
nevertheless
fine but people oh wow that's so
polarizing you know it's polarizing
suggesting that killing a terrorist with
full legal authority is somehow not okay
that's kind of polar
I even J Johnson who is the Obama
homeland security secretary said yeah of
course from had the authority for this
attack if you believe everything that
our government is saying about general
Soleimani he was a lawful military
objective and the president under his
constitutional authority as
commander-in-chief had ample domestic
legal authority to take him out without
an additional congressional
authorization the whether he was a
terrorist or a general in a military
force that was engaged in armed attacks
against our people
he was a lawful military objective okay
so there's Jay Johnson basically
spelling out for the Democrats a fact
and Trump repeats the fact in the
homeless badwin Trump says it in fact is
by the way our military leaders from the
past have been successful David Petraeus
with the surge in Iraq Admiral stavridis
both of them today we're out over the
weekend were out there saying that yes
the United States had to reestablish
returns because Iran had not been
deterred here was David Petraeus saying
that what has happened here I think is
frankly that we lost the element of
deterrence the component deterrence that
was seen as American will our drone
under 30 million dollar drone was shot
down did nothing significant response 5%
of the world's oil production taken out
of operation numerous attacks on
shipping and then attacks on our forces
ultimately of course killing an American
and wounding four of our soldiers so
ultimately the the president appears to
have decided that it was necessary to
take an action to shore up deterrence to
show that we were not going to accept
this hey Petraeus this perspective is
Trump's perspective and it is right you
may not like Trump's language but tough
ok the Trump is trying to re-establish
the deterrence that have been lost
during the Obama administration it is
indeed that simple ok time for a quick
thing I like and then a quick thing that
I hate so things that I like today once
upon a time in Hollywood is actually
quite an enjoyable film so I'm not a
huge Quentin Tarantino fan I think that
his best film is still Reservoir Dogs
Quentin Tarantino to me is sort of less
a filmmaker than he is a YouTube maker
meaning that he has so many great scenes
in these movies and the movies don't
really fit together all the way
the last 15 minutes of this movie are
just glorious my wife who hates brutal
violence and is not into it at all
she was watching the end of this movie
with me and even she was laughing
hysterically at the end of this movie
which is brutally violent I mean it is
horribly and brutally violent but it is
also some really really funny stuff but
the movie itself Brad Pitt is great in
it and so is DiCaprio DiCaprio sort of
playing DiCaprio a little bit and and
he's pretty fantastic
again it has scenes that don't really
hold together but overall it's an
enjoyable film and really what the film
is about is the death of American
masculinity in film right that's that's
really what the the movie is about what
the movie is about is Quentin Tarantino
lamenting the fact that masculinity in
film was sort of lost at the new
Hollywood European wave of the 1970s
killed off a lot of the old masculinity
in film and so it's his lament for old
Hollywood and it's also his statement
that new Hollywood should have
integrated with old Hollywood anind some
of those old Hollywood values because
the whole film is about this old western
star who is not appreciated by Hollywood
and has to go abroad to do spaghetti
westerns in order to sort of reestablish
himself in the film industry and his
buddy who is a stunt man who's the most
masculine character in the film right
he's a character who had been a world
war 2 hero and then it comes back and
he's a stunt man he can beat the crap
out of Bruce Lee and this kind of thing
the movie again is pre great in terms of
the the value system that it promotes
he's basically saying that Hollywood has
forgotten what it's like to be a man and
his and his lamented what it is to be a
man and that when you don't have real
men in society or culturally when you
when you disparage real men what you end
up with his greater violence not less
violence so in its own way I take on the
Iran situation and once upon a time in
Hollywood not really but kind of here's
a little bit of the trailer
[Music]
I'm Sharon Tate I'm in the movie you're
in this that's me
I play Miss Carlson the klutz
[Music]
there's so much that that's really good
and true about this movie the critics
were sometimes all over the the Terence
Tarantino for the great sin of not
having given Margot Robbie more lines
Margot Robbie is a central character in
the film if you really believe that the
number of lines in a film is
representative of how important
characters are it's because you've never
seen a film before it's called the film
because you watch it if it were an audio
recording that would be slightly
different it's got a lot of great scenes
there's a lot of good stuff in this film
I really enjoyed it and I think that
there there there's been a pretty good
year for film I'll be honest I thought
last year was a terrible year for film
I've seen a bunch of good movies this
year really at the end of the year and
cool that's kind of anything okay time
for a quick thing that I hate okay so
speaking of Hollywood celebrities who
are just complete doof I and who were
supposed to take seriously about Iran
apparently Colin Kaepernick tweeted in
response to the killing of Soleimani and
he tweeted out this is of course is the
famous quarterback who's a great
American patriot don't let anyone tell
you different just cuz he note for the
national anthem and more socks with
pictures of cops as pigs on them don't
let anyone tell you that Colin
Kaepernick is not the height of American
patriotism descent is patriotism and the
height of dissent treason is the
greatest form of patriotism Colin
Kaepernick was a patriot such a patriot
that he got a Nike contract for kneeling
because sometimes you have to stand up
even if it means losing everything or
kneel even if it means losing everything
or kneel even if it means getting a
million dollar contract from Nike or
Neil even it means getting rid of the
Betsy Ross flag on sneakers well done
Nike so who is Colin Kaepernick that's
great civil rights hero this icon
standing up to American aggression he's
one of the what a garbage human being
here's what he tweeted over the weekend
America has always sanctioned and
besieged black and brown bodies both at
home and abroad
America militarism is the weapon wielded
by American imperialism to enforce its
policing and plundering of the non-white
world so in other words he's angry that
soleimani was killed because it was
about
run he he was angry that soy money was
killed and he called it an act of
American imperialism to kill a terror
leader who was killing by the way almost
entirely black and brown people because
he is a garbage human ok garbage humans
sweet stuff like this this is a it's
it's a ridiculous a historical
proposition first of all America is
always sanctioned embassy always
sanction and besieged black and brown
bodies both at home and abroad really so
you're going to have to explain to me
what World War two was about in Europe
because it seems like they were fighting
Nazis and the Nazis were pretty white
also it seems as though many of the
black and brown people that the United
States has had to go to war with in the
past were mainly killing other black and
brown people that was sort of the the
big problem if you think that American
foreign policy is driven by white black
green yellow blue you are wrong that is
just a lie that is just a lie and the
notion that has anything to do with like
the historic legacy of slavery and Jim
Crow that we killed Soleimani because we
hate brown people like what in the eff
also this American militarism is the
weapon wielded by American imperialism
because nothing says imperialism quite
less like expending trillions of dollars
for no actual monetary benefits of the
United States
nothing says imperialism quite like not
actually just taking over Iraq and
running it
nothing says imperialism quite like
involving ourselves in conflicts around
the world for protection of human rights
like in Yugoslavia for example because
we're policing and plundering the
non-white world plundering the non-white
world has Colin Kaepernick ever spent
like any serious time in other parts of
the world one of the things that you
will notice about the way that so many
people on the Left operate is that when
you look anything long enough you start
to see shades in it and when you start
to look at anything just right up close
you start to see shades and variations
in textures shades and variations in in
the actual color scheme of the thing
that you're looking at any object just
visually if you pull back from the
object and suddenly you see it
contrasted suddenly you recognize oh
wait a second in sharp relief there's
not that much contrast here but with the
rest of the world there is a massive
contrast right if you if you pull back
from a from a graphic that is black and
gray and you see all the variation
you're right clothes on you see all the
variations
black-and-gray then you pull back is on
a white piece of paper suddenly that
black and gray graphic right that black
and gray square in the middle of a paper
it looks very different in contrast with
the white paper all around it okay the
same thing is true when it comes to
viewing America in the world if you look
at America and your real up close on it
it's like viewing a Seurat paint thing
too close all you see is the dots all
you see is all of the flaws in the
painting and then you pull back here
like oh the rest of the world most
places our garbage most places are
really horrible to live most places have
facilitated mass murder most places
facilitate great human suffering most
places are way worse than the you know
like all places in fact are way worse
than the United States on the vast
variety of topics and yet you get Colin
Kaepernick suggesting that it's American
militarism that's really the problem
this a historical ignorant racist crap
is just that a historical ignorant
racist crap from Colin Kaepernick
well-done Nike just well done but it
wasn't just Colin Kaepernick celebrity
sounding off on all this to get Michael
Moore one of our again moral betters
talking about the Iran situation Michael
Moore who declares that he he likes
Cuban health care yeah you should go
there for his weight loss program
Michael Moore tweeted out hello fellow
Americans do you know this man's picture
of Qasem Soleimani
responsible for hundreds of American
deaths responsible for terror attacks
all over the world responsible for
keeping his own people under the thumb
of a brutal dictatorship is it hello
fellow Americans do you know this man
did you know he was your enemy what
never heard of him by the end of today
you will be trained to hate him you will
be glad Trump had him assassinated you
will do as you are told
get ready to send your sons and
daughters off to war okay so much is
idiotic and wrong about this first of
all your sons and daughters if by this
means there's gonna be a draft there
ain't gonna be a draft
I saw people posting this article over
the weekend people are calling up the
Selective Service and asking about the
draft yeah they did this with a rock to
was a draft reinstituted the draft is
never coming back it's not a thing
that's ever going to happen again but
Michael Moore saying that that Soleimani
was not your enemy but now you've been
trained to hate him most people hadn't
heard of Osama bin Laden even after the
USS Cole until 9/11 did that mean he
wasn't our enemy and he was actually
just a nice guy with a beard or in Colin
Kaepernick's view a brown person
attacked by the United States Michael
Moore what a moral imbecile he is just
an absolute moral but don't worry he
black
i sat alongside Jimmy Carter at the 2004
Democratic National Convention it was
Michael Moore and Jimmy Carter in a box
at the 2004 DNC don't tell me about the
moral superiority of the Democratic
Party
do not start that nonsense and then you
get cardi B was endorsed Bernie Sanders
is my understanding these Bernie Sanders
again the greatest wisest and fairest
among us cardi B tweeted out now these
memes are bleep but bleep ain't no joke
especially being from New York it's sad
this man is putting Americans live in
danger dumbest moved from did till date
I'm filing for my Nigerian citizenship
all right I think the world can live
without your your brand of so-called
music cardi B if you if you really
choose to live in Nigeria if you think
that you are rich and famous and safe in
Nigeria have at it enjoy right truly the
level of astonishing ignorance on the
part of our celebrity class it's what
Ricky Gervais she was targeted at the
Golden Globes absolutely correct because
look at these dolts look at them hey
Michael like I understand cardi B is not
considered anybody's idea of an
intellectual except the left I mean left
who've actually promoted videos of her
endorsing Bernie Sanders as though her
position on politics is well informed
Colin Kapernick was actually touted as a
thinker he's actually touted as a civil
rights hero he's been on the cover of
magazines as somebody who's leading the
fight for change Michael Moore has been
featured by the Democratic Party for
years so blurring the line between
ignorance and absolute moral
ridiculousness it's these so I'm
supposed to trust these people like that
I'm gonna take this seriously this is
the perspective I make no mistake when
you hear the more highfalutin Democrats
talking about how Trump is endangering
the world they just don't like the fact
that Trump has given the lie to ten
years of bad foreign policy by the Obama
administration
pulling out precipitously from Iraq
allowing Iran to fill the gap allowing
Iran to fill the gap in Syria paying the
Iranians off right all of that was a
failed foreign policy
it was obviously a failed foreign policy
and reestablishing deterrence is
designed to prevent war not to create
war as Mike Pompeo says he says listen
we're correcting eight years of
appeasement here and you all want to
pretend that Barack Obama had this under
control
the only reason you think that is
because your is
because you you were born yesterday or
possibly last night we suffered from
eight years of Iranian support from
America we gave them billions of dollars
we gave them resources we allowed come
to countries to trade with them to build
up their economy what we are now having
to correct for is the enormous economic
activity that took place during this
Iranian nuclear deal that president from
Riley got out of in May of 2018 it's
taken a little bit of time and it will
continue to take time but we are going
to restore deterrence without deterrence
America does not have a workable foreign
policy because otherwise you now make it
that America may have to fight three or
four separate Wars real wars on all
different fronts the purpose of
deterrence is the least possible
expenditure of force to prevent the
broader use of force by one of our
enemies that would necessitate us using
broader force the Obama administration's
plan is you just pay these people off
until the alligator is big enough to eat
you or at least take off a limb that was
an unsuccessful strategy Trump
recognizes that that that's what's going
on the United States will not end up in
an overt massive shooting war with Iran
there will be low-level conflict for a
while here but if if deterrence is
reestablished it really boxes the
Iranians in it's a real problem for them
there's what Pompeo knows this is what
Trump knows and you may not like how
Trump phrases it but tough Barack Obama
phrased obviously foolish moral ideas
beautifully Donald Trump phrases good
moral ideas poorly I'd much rather have
the latter than have the former because
in the end the content of the moral
ideas implemented in the world the
content of the of the useful defense
ideas implemented the world is much more
important than how they are articulated
especially because everybody knows what
Trump saying anyway and he may be
brusque but everybody understands that
what he's saying is you heard us and
it's gonna hurt you a lot worse all
right we'll be back here later to deal
with two additional hours of comment of
commentary otherwise we will see you
here tomorrow
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director pavel white house key
edited by adam sai events audio is mixed
by micro Mina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright day Lee Weyer
2019 hey everybody its Andrew Clavin
host of the Andrew Clavin show you know
some people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clavin
[Music]